hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda julie de riaño
[Música]
la integración es uno de los procesos
más complejos en el camino hacia el
refugio en ese tránsito hacia la
inclusión los refugiados juegan un papel
importante como agentes para el
desarrollo con sus profesiones
habilidades y talentos tienen la
oportunidad de fortalecer el país de
acogida si así se les permite en este
programa veremos dos historias que
hablan de proyectos de refugiados que
desde el arte y el periodismo buscan
llamar la atención a cristóbal es un
venezolano refugiado en parís dejó su
patria pero llevó su talento hasta la
ciudad luz donde plasma mediante el arte
las preocupaciones de los franceses
sobre la pandemia
cristóbal imprime sus ideas gracias al
apoyo local veamos el informe preparado
por erika olavarría
en estas telas este artista plástico
venezolano imprimió las preguntas que
los franceses se intercambiaban en redes
sociales enfrentados a la pandemia y los
sucesivos confinamientos es su última
obra cuál será su último plan
o su pequeño placer
de mañana antes de que nos recojan y
empecé a meterme en grupos de franceses
de facebook y a ver qué posteaban y
empezar a darme cuenta de que me podrían
servir como discurso artístico porque sí
guardaba las preguntas cuando otra
persona la leyera en su mente iba a
tener un diálogo y va a tener una
respuesta
cristóbal utilizaba su arte como
herramienta de protesta política en
contra del régimen de maduro en el 2017
decidió instalarse en francia me
avisaron que estaba en una lista de la
policía casualmente me invitaron me
habían invitado a parís a dar una
conferencia precisamente sobre lo que
estábamos haciendo varios artistas de
venezuela con el tema de las protestas y
aproveche esta oportunidad para salir de
venezuela
desde su llegada a parís cristóbal
cuenta con un espacio de trabajo que se
lo brinda la asociación agencia de
artistas en el exilio que acoge a 150
refugiados políticos de 45
nacionalidades bajo pues de arafo han
expuesto a bailes damos un espacio de
trabajo pero también la posibilidad de
encontrar gente y oportunidades
profesionales para que los artistas
puedan retomar su vida profesional
juveniles tomando la profesión
en el caso de aller línea está flautista
que durante más de 15 años perteneció al
sistema de orquestas venezolanas la
agencia le permitió reencontrarse con el
público
[Música]
el ritmo de conciertos por ejemplo que
yo tenía en venezuela para nada lo tengo
aquí y pues aquí me dieron la
oportunidad de otra vez estar delante
del público y eso lo agradezco mucho
ahora el otro sueño de anger link es
cambiar su visa de estudiante por un
permiso de residencia y trabajo para
poder formar a futuros músicos en parís
en españa' un grupo de periodistas
sirios abrió la primera revista digital
dirigida por refugiados en el país se
trata de un medio que busca acercar a la
comunidad árabe en europa con noticias e
historias sobre inmigrantes en dos
idiomas el proyecto cuenta con el apoyo
de la fundación española por causa que
promueve el periodismo de investigación
sobre temas de migración
esta es la historia
ok baudio en 2019 de siria es periodista
y está refugiado en españa fue reportero
en derá cuna de la revuelta de 2011
contra bachar al asad la sangrienta
guerra civil lo llevó al exilio es una
historia que comparte con otros tres
colegas hay jan mohamed y musa ahora los
cuatro trabajan en una misma oficina en
madrid y están al frente de vaina na una
revista online de noticias en árabe
presentada como la primera en el país
dirigida por refugiados quedamos en
ventana
ofrecer información útil de calidad a la
comunidad árabe en españa y al mismo
tiempo creemos tejer lazos entre el
mundo árabe y la comunidad árabe en
españa y los refugiados inmigrantes y
también con los españoles sus primeros
artículos cuentan historias sobre
migrantes y refugiados pero buscan
ampliar sus horizontes y ofrecer
información útil a la comunidad árabe en
europa
y me gusta trabajar sobre los refugiados
porque yo soy refugiado y yo sé muy bien
cómo viven los refugiados y qué
problemas tienen qué dificultades tienen
para vivir aquí en español y también me
gustaría trabajar sobre historias de
éxito y aunque agradecen la seguridad
qué significa estar en españa
denunciando racismo contra los
extranjeros en situaciones simples como
alquilar un lugar para vivir y no no no
me imaginaba que llegué aquí a españa
como un refugiado o como migrante me
imaginaba que llegó aquí a españa como
un viajero estudiante pero está hacia la
vida teníamos que salir de gira de mi
país o escapamos de la muerte del salir
al final que estoy aquí en madrid no hay
nada está dirigido a un millón de
arabófonos residentes en españa pero
además sus historias son traducidas al
español con lo que esperan alcanzar más
lectores
la diversidad cultural y la experiencia
profesional de los refugiados puede
fortalecer a las sociedades que los
acogen si se permite su integración
hasta que inmigrantes de france24
los invitamos a comentar en nuestras
redes sociales con el hashtag migrantes
f24 sigan con más información en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]